it's time for screen junkies movie bides
Oh what in the world you guys it's movie
fights what's happening oh yeah we got a
handful of people in the studio giving a
whoa and a clap and we've got a handful
of fighters at this table who are ready
to get in home let's meet today's
combatants first he is the host of the
cancel too soon podcast and one of the
host of the critically acclaimed podcast
coming soon welcome back the Biebs
William Viviani hello well what's
happening my man well I got those
podcasts nice yeah oh you should feel
right at home with that thing in front
of you I do
speaking of podcasts our next combatant
is the host of the meaning of podcast
and I'd like to welcome back he's a
producer for the schmoes ace Cabrera
thank you for having me it's a it's my
first official movie fight oh wow this
is my first time competing in an actual
movie fights last time I did the
free-for-all movie but yes yes but now
you are in real deal movie fights
correct um what'd you do to get ready I
looked at myself in the mirror and gave
myself a pep speech is that is that what
we still do No oh no that is classic all
right yes absolutely that's what I do
every morning when I wake up but every
night before got about or you are a big
bright shining star
thank you man you sir are worthy also
worthy this is making her movie fights
debut you know we're from popcorn talk
afterbuzz screen junkies news she's
gonna be in all sorts of cons all summer
long welcome to the party Elena Jordan
thanks for being here Elena what did you
do to get ready for movie fights um well
I had a cupcake because it's my birthday
[Applause]
doesn't that become like domain doesn't
have to come free and we're taking the
chance the singing portion of the show
is over
I already feel like a winner thanks guys
Elena thank you so much for being here
and happy birthday and he is coming in
guns blazing with fact checks
especially with happy birthday rights to
the song Denver I'm buddy I was just
thinking of the last mirror
inspirational speech or somebody said I
can't get out welcome from Boogie Nights
yes yes I'm very nice thank you sir yeah
and the voice of the people the conduit
of the Internet and a voice of reason
and the delightful Daniel Radford hello
as per usual the pose will be going up
once all of the fighters have have
stated their opening arguments that way
we can make sure that the polls are
going to be based on the arguments there
are some fun Twitter polls but the poll
of accounts for this one is going to be
the YouTube poll we'll also be putting
in some directions you can see them down
in the description people will be
notifying you when they'll be up in the
chat and as for you I will be checking
the hashtag movie fights live so if you
have anything awesome you want to send
me corgis as Papa how cause um dank me
know those gank me go ahead and send
those right on over and I will do a good
job crediting and showing love okay bye
Thank You Danielle just a little
reminder how things work here it's a
best-of-seven game the first competitor
to get four points goes home the winner
there are three regular round questions
and then two of our combatants will head
into the speed round where there are
four speed round questions and they'll
Duke it out in the event of a tie we
Scots tie breakers good times so are you
guys feeling it yeah feeling it yes Dan
can y'all feeling it let's do this
ji-ae drop that success package
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You jte you always bring a
handsome package to the table he's a big
bright shining star okay so Deadpool 2
comes out this weekend and our views are
really good so flip the script we want
to know what's the all-time most
disappointing superhero sequel okay I
will set Squeakquel I don't think that's
one of our answers no yes absolutely
after the first one built us up so much
yes what is the most disappointing
superhero sequel of all time and we'll
start with the gentleman to my left
William Beebe Ani
what do you got okay picture it the year
is 1983 you're in a movie theater there
aren't a lot of superhero movies out
there but we just had two of the best of
all time we had Superman the movie one
of the most biggest most popular
blockbusters ever they topped that with
Superman 2 where he fought a whole bunch
of Kryptonians giant fights epic
storylines and in the third one Superman
is gonna fight Superman and oh my god
it's stuck it's co-starring one of the
funniest comedians in history Richard
Pryor you're sitting down for Superman 3
and the first like half hour is about
Richard Pryor in the unemployment line
learning how to type on computers
getting a new job working for Robert
Vaughn skiing off of buildings and then
Oh Superman
Superman's finally here and then he goes
back to Smallville he goes like this
Smallville for a high school reunion for
what feels like half the movie and when
they finally get together
Superman splits and splits he's a jerk
and that's about half the movie and then
he fights himself in a big metaphoric
fight in a junkyard that looks like crap
and then someone turns into a cyborg and
then thank God it's over it's not funny
it's not exciting it's still one of the
worst superhero movies ever made and
after that buildup of the first two who
disappointing Wow thank you for giving
us such a smooth synopsis of the film as
well they're talking about all right
thank you bibs ace what do you got yeah
so before spider-man before
we had this superhero craze the first
superhero movie that wanted to take its
genre seriously as the comic book
sometimes took it was grind Singers
x-men followed up by x-men -
unfortunately when Bryan Singer love to
do Superman Returns we had Brett Ratner
jump in for x-men The Last Stand which
is my choice for most most disappointing
sequel because of what was set up in the
previous two films of what Bryan Singer
was attempting to accomplish with these
x-men movies which was stayed true to
the essence and the tone and the theme
of the movies which is a very political
very difficult subject that it hits on
an x-men the last and just decides to
throw that out the window forget
continuity forget character motivations
and just do something completely
different which turns out to be
incredibly disappointing all right
x-men The Last Stand Elena I feel like
the question is not what's the worst
superhero sequel but what's the most
disappointing and so for me for Sam
Raimi to give us two perfect spider-man
movies and then take a big ol crap on
our hearts with a third one with all the
same ingredients the same actors the
same characters than introducing all
these unnecessary characters with other
movies when we get a change in director
there is somewhat of an anticipation of
there could be a bit of a disappointment
whereas when you're given all of the
same mix you're expecting the best time
of your life and instead you're giving
pizza time which is wildly disappointing
unnecessary and then we have to top it
off not one not two but three
inexplicable and wildly wildly
inappropriate musical numbers makes
absolutely no sense completely
incongruous and completely undoes some
of the most heart-wrenching parts of the
first one of finding Uncle Ben's killer
and then saying all of a sudden that
wasn't Uncle Ben's killer but then never
circling back to explain why Peter isn't
upset that he apparently led a random
man fall to his death in the first movie
all right there you have it three
disappointing films which one is most
disappointing fight it out okay first
off Pizza Thomas spider-man - I was
going to say that yeah
three is a movie that I actually defend
now I'm not saying it's the best
superhero movie ever but it does give
you more of everything that we saw and
all the Sam Raimi movies the
interpersonal drama with Peter and MJ
and Harry Osborn
builds to a real huge intensity and that
ends up being the main story arc of the
movie for me it's the Harry Osborn
turning into a really insidious almost
Shakespearean villain by the end of it
all of that stuff really really plays I
love all that the problem with that
being the trope that they go to amnesia
which is Harry bumps his head at the
beginning when you think that this is
going to be this epic battle that's
gonna occur later on and sin it happens
early on he then just forgets who
spider-man is conveniently it goes to
too many tropes that are too sophomoric
for this point in the film franchise
spider-man has always been a soap opera
though it's always been about these
relationship dynamics not just there but
but the thing for me that defines both
films is Superman part 1 in Part 2
spider-man Part one and Part two both
have a fun kind of energetic feel and in
the third films of each franchise they
kind of go slightly overboard whereas in
my film franchises we develop we we deal
with themes of racism we deal with
themes of discrimination we deal with
themes of feeling like an outcast of
being politicized as being an enemy and
it opens up the first x-men literally
opens up in a concentration camp that
shows the tone of the film the second
act x-men opens up with a white house
attempted murder which only furthers the
politicise and the third one turns it
into a pulpy fun one for me it's the
destruction of the tone and the themes
of the film's that defines it whereas
the you're right the Sam Raimi wants
Part one and two but there's still fun
there's still winking at the camera
quite a bit
the third one he just winks slightly
more that's what's most disappointing
you expect that could be a possibility
when the reins are handed over to a new
director but it doesn't take away from
the fact that it's the most
disappointing sequel it's not
necessarily it's not no because no okay
listen it's a shift it's a shift it
changes a bit in tone I agree the themes
are all still there we are looking at in
the plot of x-men 3 this new invention
this mutant curing drug
Magneto because of that opening because
of what we see in world war two is
concerned is gonna lead to a modern
eugenics project which is exactly what
is literally happening throughout the
narrative perpetuates all of those
things all of them are in there and then
he undercuts him when he starts doing
one-liners and starts throwing out shows
you know what happens when a tow gets
hit by lightning it's always that's
that's not winning it's the full
narrative of the first two whereas the
third spider-man movie incorporates way
too many villains you never get fully
developed characters and because the
stakes are lowered in the third one you
don't have that same dynamic whereas
there is a it makes sense there's a
complete storyline for the first three
for all of the x-men movies going from
x2 into last stand and having angel
represent that entire story arc in a
three-part three act series having each
of those movies representing those third
acts and then represented in a microcosm
for one character I feel like we hardly
see Angel for me for me the thing that
takes people out of sequels the most
when you go into the first movie you say
I like this movie because it's a drama
on what the x-men would be it's it's
literally taking the source material
seriously whereas when you jump into
spider-man you like spider-man and
spider-man 2 because it's funny it's fun
in dr. Jenna care about it because we
care about the characters which is why I
disagree with your argument about how
the stakes aren't that low the stakes
are extreme the stakes are actually
we've got Harry dubs art we got Peter
losing his relationship with MJ we've
got Harry destroying his opposing best
friend we've got Peter actually starting
to have fun with being a superhero which
is the antithesis of him it begins a
steady cycle to his downfall when the
end of the movie is a real downer
because the stakes were so high and I
want to just say your off-the-cuff
remark about how Oh Superman 3 was just
a perpetuation of the fun 1 have you
seen Superman 3 it's not fun it's
actually what is boring and turgid but
it's attempting to be funny ronk
Superman it is awesome and he tells a
little kid that he has
three and say this is so bad it's good
moments in spider-man 3 though funny fry
versus I think my thing is when you hear
superhero movies you especially now with
the dark and greedy DC franchise let's
go back to the fun Superman times right
let's go back to the fun spider-man
times where as x-men wasn't that fun
stuff and then hey off but it tried to
be something different not to be the one
it sets up in the first two movies the
payoff and then it even gives us some
twists like you're expecting I sweet on
rogue to get together and then they said
early that's that's part of the reasons
why because it is great she's great on
the page I'm not saying that I'm saying
the relationship between Ellen Page
Shadowcat and then rode with Iceman is
broke picks no one rogue says I picked
myself thing Peter at the end of
spider-man 3 and listen MJ and Wednesday
Phoebe moves right here's the thing
giving them anything to do it has a ton
of great stuff in spider-man 3 that
opening Green Goblin fight is fantastic
that huge fight between the Green Goblin
spider-man venom and Sam and at the end
is a masterwork of choreography there's
a lot of exciting the scene with Sandman
like pulls out of the sand pulls himself
together at the end I find a hauntingly
beautiful piece of cinema and yeah I
even like the musical numbers because
Sam Raimi has always had a dorky sense
of humor if you like that bit in
spider-man 2 where it was the song from
Butch Cassidy and Sundance Kid they just
gave you more of that in the next one
that's exactly what we expect whereas
you don't instrument in Superman 3 for
Superman to take a backseat to Richard
Pryor who isn't allowed to be funny and
then spend most of the movie knocks at
spider-man in spider-man 3 is Lisa's
he's got the venom sued and he's
actually like feeling things about it
this is just turning Superman into a
side joke in a movie called Superman 3
it's not called Richard Pryor 1 it's
Superman
3 and he's gone William go ahead and use
this as your final thoughts Superman 3
sucks and one thing I've noticed
is that all of you guys you have a lot
of arguments about why x-men 3 is good
and why spider-man 3 is underrated or
here's here's the thing no one has any
arguments about why Superman 3 is good
because it is boring it's because it
looks stupid it's not funny it's
literally what's the funny joke in
Superman 3 and it's exceptionally
disappointing because we had two movies
with a good sense of humor and a lot of
action and now I have a movie with no
sense of humor even though it's got one
of the greatest comedians ever and
there's not a lot of action the biggest
action is Superman trying to save a
coffee crop who gives a crap
also slowest Lane is out of it so at
least you have continuation that the
characters you like Lois Lane is gone
for most of this movie it doesn't work
it's really disappointing if you watch
the first two Superman movies all right
ace go ahead and give us your finger was
trying to establish a very serious very
dramatic politicized dealing with actual
issues that we deal with in the real
world and then x-men The Last Stand took
away character motivations took away the
tones and themes of the film's which to
me is the most important whereas
spider-man 1 and 2 and Superman wanted
to still has a very light tone it's very
much targeted towards children
whereas x-men tried to not target
children necessarily and try to target
adults for me super Superman 3 and
spider-man 3 aren't simply taking the
tone and expanding it more and
attempting to make it more funny whereas
x-men the last stand does that on a film
that's very much more serious all right
thank you ace Elena go ahead and give us
your final thoughts x-men last stand
wraps up some of the main plot points
that are established in the first two
movie in a way in movies in a way that
makes sense that doesn't have
incongruities like spider-man 3 without
having these shifts in tone like
spider-man 3 that makes no sense at all
now the main thing too is that you're
looking at the levels of disappointment
and when you have the most brilliant
cake you've ever tasted in your life and
then the Baker is the same Baker they
have the same ingredients they have the
same cook time they give you a
half-baked piece of crap when you were
expecting brilliance you wonder what
went wrong whereas if there's a change
in the Baker you go well there is a
problem and there's the potential for
the problem and on top of that
when you look at the poster for Superman
3 you see that it looks like it's going
to be a silly over-the-top comedy with a
giant hatted Richard Pryor you're not
expecting that this is going to be
cinematic brilliance you're expecting a
fun romp which is exactly what it is and
yet I'm alright Wow how about it um note
to self don't go back to that Baker okay
Dan Moreau what's going on with the
facts I mean this is pretty much opinion
based and Viviani did a little in-game
fact-check so of them that I don't
really have anything to add as far as
the factual basis of this really just
listening to all of their arguments
which were very passionate absolutely
every front for sure everybody came into
this guns blazing and there was some
great stuff thrown down
I think Elena you made an awesome point
in your argument letting us know that
and reminding us that this is the most
disappointing superhero sequel not the
worst superhero sequel and those good
reminder to meet to listen to your
arguments and frame it through that lens
Bibbs I think you had a nice takedown of
Elena with calling out stuff that you
liked in spider-man 3 and from you know
Sandman
pulling out his massive hands and
everything I don't know if I caught
hauntingly beautiful beautiful and ace
had a lot of good points as well at the
end of the day I feel like ace really
painted the picture of how it got
wrenched out of him how what the movie
what the franchise had set up it didn't
add up to it and you painted a picture
of a really bad movie you painted a
picture of things you didn't like but
the most disappointment came from ace so
I'm going with ace and x-men last stand
really disappoint damn I came out it a
little bit differently and I think that
everyone did a very good job of selling
why their movie was not good so I don't
think anyone really made any points
again that's the other one there it's a
bad movie fights and it's about taking
the
openings and you know Viviani gave both
of them a chance to really dig their
claws into Superman 3 you know he said
you know I agree like there were good
stuff brought up about spider-man 3
there was good stuff brought up but
eczema in the last stand and I think
that you know Billy only opened the door
to launch into like you tell me what's
good about this movie tell and when
nobody really did and so that to me put
me onto the on each side which is that
everybody did such a great job of
painting why the movie was bad and yet I
felt like the other two choices there
were things brought up positively about
both and nothing really to me was
brought up to that level by Superman 3
so I'm actually going with Viviani all
right there you go it is one for Bibbs
one for Ace let's go to Daniel Radford
to break the tie alright and going over
to the pole as of right now it is very
close but we've got x-men The Last Stand
at 37 percent Superman 3 at 33 percent
and spider-man 3 at 28 percent see
people like spider-man 3 maybe a little
bit more than the other movie so ace you
get the point
Danielle any other good stuff sections a
lot of people were saying Batman vs
Superman which y'all can have that fight
on your own if you go over to David
pockets 9 d over on Twitter he's got
like a dissertation about why it's
fantastic for rise of the Silver Surfer
not even really me me just really
interesting and then a couple of people
said Batman and Robin which first of all
how dare you good it's so good good you
know it's Footloose and fancy-free and
it's got bat nipples right yes but sorry
Batman forever true
so they set it up it's not disappointed
they give you exactly what you wanted
last there you go you knew you were
getting bat nipples Thank You babes
welcome let's go to question number 2
movie fights okay so we got the brand
new trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody this
week talking a little Queen wilfordii
mercury what is the best movie about a
real or fictional musician best movie
about a real or fictional musician
and it's the second question we're going
with player number two ace alrighty
I picked a movie that I feel like is one
of the not only one of the Gress the
best directorial debuts from a director
that recently won an Academy Award for
Best Director for another movie but I
feel like this movie is a true
exploration of a musician of an obsessed
artist of an artist that is so
passionate about his music and that is
whiplash I chose whiplash starring miles
teller who gives an amazing performance
this won the Academy Award for editing
as well as for JK Simmons a key Simmons
who gives an incredible performance that
I feel lasts a long time and is going to
continue to go down in history as one of
the greatest performances as a teacher
as an obsessed musician as well alright
whiplash Elena I feel that this is not
only one of the best movies about a
musician but also just one of the best
movies of all time almost famous
Cameron COEs mm love letter to the music
industry and to his time as a music
journalist which adds a level of realism
to this movie that a lot of over
dramatic sized movies kind of lack and
feel somewhat forced in a lot of music
based films this one also gives us a
full dynamic range of the impact of
music and the impact of the work not
just for the artists and how it affects
the artists themselves but more
importantly how its received by an
audience and there's not only received
but how it actually can change the lives
and influence these people who are given
this gift that they feel that they
receive that adds a level of pressure to
the artist that is exemplified in this
film and in the words of Penny Lane
herself imagine loving one band or one
silly little piece of music so much that
it physically hurts this movie brings
that pain it brings that realism and it
brings out love to life
Thank You Elena yeah we got whiplash we
got almost famous two great movies bibs
what do you got all right I'm gonna talk
about one of the best movies ever made I
know a couple of you've already made
that claim but this time it's real
Milosh Foreman's 1984 classic Amadeus
it's not only about one of the greatest
musicians in history it's also about one
of the most mediocre musicians in
history giving you two sides of the
artistic experience all
at once all within a narrative which is
intensely exciting transforms classical
music into something that feels
incredibly contemporary and potent and
valuable and shows the dark side of
genius the upside of genius and the
ultimate tragedy and knowing that you
may love music but you're not good
enough at it
Amadeus is an incredible acting tour de
force it's an accrediting it's
incredible filmmaking tour de force and
there was a reason we still talk about
it to this day
brilliant motion picture alright yet
we're talking about it right now go
ahead and fight it out everybody okay so
here's my thing with almost famous
almost famous is not about the musicians
it is about the fans now that's a good
story but it's not really about the
people making the music they're really
side characters Billy Crudup has some
scenes but we're really looking at
Patrick Fugit scare achter the entire
time and you can say all you want about
how it's about how music inspires the
fans but this isn't about music this is
about the musician and when they're the
side characters and the narrative even
when they showed a picture from almost
famous of the two protagonists of almost
famous
neither of them were musicians so that's
my take on almost famous although it is
good and as for whiplash whiplash is a
really really really irresponsible movie
about obsession it is brilliant but it
is not about music music is actually
incidental to that music is the thing he
is obsessed with but he could have been
just as obsessed with dancing he could
be dispossessed about painting the
participants about writing and you would
have basically the same narrative it's
all about how far you can push someone
until they break whereas Amadeus is
about the creative spirit from multiple
angles competing all the time
simultaneously to show how the greatest
musician in history arguably was
underappreciated in his time why his
music lingers and how the industry can
destroy you even in the past all right
you two want to say something while at
Viviani crap I do agree that whiplash is
not about the music it is about
obsession it also glorifies abuse in
many ways this is very mushy and not
very thought-out movie that also is
makes no sense drumline is more
realistic on moving because I'm not
beating there
bloody pulps which is completely
incongruous em is counterproductive for
an actual musician real drummers pan
this movie as a movie that doesn't make
sense because having somebody audition
for six straight hours to the point that
they are politically incapable of
drumming is not does not interesting
characters it's not a dance is not
actually a movie about Mozart it's a
movie about a novella that was
fictionalized about Sully Aires
relationship with Mozart which is not
real because in fact he hired Salieri to
teach his son which also as historians
have proven is a laughably an accurate
account of Mozart's real life on top of
that you just say that it's a movie
about the music the music is these long
interludes that detract from the actual
story line instead of expediting the
plot which is exactly what the music and
all do you need to see how comes a true
character in the film it is all about
the music and to say that the musicians
aren't the key when one of the most
iconic scenes from that is the I'm of
golden god scene taken from Duane
Allman's actual real real-life situation
which was not him making music that was
a sight note in his life and here's the
fan is him being ostracized by his own
band members when you're having a
situation that is about an artist who
was crumbling under the pressure that
his fans have created that his actual
art has created and that his band
members who are supposed to had his back
had put him in a situation where he is
now unable to create because he's so
self reflective that he is basically
crippled with his fans to pull him out
of that scenario right now this is so
awesome I'm gonna talk with Amadeus
first stuff you need to see the
performances in order to understand the
genius of Amadeus and you need to
contrast the genius of Amadeus with the
adequacy of Salieri now your your
argument that oh it's not true - life is
meaningless when the literal prompt was
real or fictional so this is both
simultaneously we get actual ass
elements of history and we get and
actually really fascinating ideas are
brilliant when Abraham is basically so
subtle that he's lacking any emotion at
all and you have the original Mozart
Simon Callow making an appearance and
doing nothing for me is brilliant about
it says about musician which is for me
this is about miles teller as a musician
just out unrealistic situations of car
Texas Chainsaw Massacre is a story about
a musician an actual person a character
study about a human being a person who
is obsessed with his art in order to
succeed in life he has a purpose in his
purpose is to be the greatest drummer
that can be he chooses the jazz and I
feel like if we're talking about musical
scenes this movie has written the
greatest incredible musical seats at the
very end of the movie that gives one of
the greatest crescendos and finishes
talking about the best movie about a
musician you have to ask yourself what
is the best and there's a certain level
of craftsmanship - whiplash I'm not
gonna deny but at the same time the best
movie musician happened to with the
certain taste in your mouth can be
broken and part of almost famous whereas
it detracts from both Amadeus and
whiplash and model disease is literally
about obsessed composer just stop and
then play music for an extended period
we're good to see Stillwater perform
near as I can tell they suck each other
we can't talk over eternal
oh yes because I'm here to try to direct
traffic a little bit bids you're in
timeout for a moment talk to us the
phenomenal Mozart music video that goes
on for a very long time with unrealistic
plot lines and wasted casting and
performances that are basically
indicative of somebody who doesn't
really understand the true source
material and are trying to expedite a
plot and an extra drama into a situation
that portrays Mozart as sophomoric and
immature when in actuality this is all
pulled from letters that he wrote to his
cousin time and place he's not flirting
at dinner parties he was actually a
genius and to reduce an actual genius
and to say that this is based on that
person when almost all of it is
fictionalized it's irresponsible to say
the least and also has music that
detract from a story about a musician
okay a fictionalized version of that
real character my problem with almost
famous is is is the first initial
question the question is best movie
about a musician almost famous literally
has a perspective a perspective of
someone who's in the media a person who
is visualizing the music a person who
use the enemy as they point correct
complete view because the musicians are
able to see themselves for who they are
explanation from beginning to end from
the conception of the art the production
of the art the reception of the art and
the impact of the at the same time guys
otherwise no one wins see for me that
that detracts from the movie itself
because for me it's about the musician
itself his journey his art what he's
obsessed with what he wants and that's
what we get with whiplash we get with
awesome any performances by JK Simmons
who gives his performance which is sweat
to the Oscars II almonds go ahead and
make this your final charcoal and put a
pin in it for me Amadeus is too
concerned with making mozar a cartoon
character a person who is so over the
top that it's hysterical it's funny it
doesn't feel like a real musician that
you can grasp on
two and four almost famous I really do
feel like the question itself just
attracts from it when it says it's about
a musician where this is about a person
who is following a band who is
journeying throughout the band's life
whereas whiplash is a journey of an
artist going through literally at 1 X 2
X 3 which for him is realizing where he
wants to be falling and then rising
again when he comes face to face with a
person who is obsessed with music as
much as he is and that's what he gets at
the end of the movie when we get actual
music being played beautifully thank you
ace Elena go ahead and give us your
final thoughts multiple times throughout
whiplash I was forced to go oh come on
because it was just so unrealistic and
when that's the case that completely
takes you out of the narrative on top of
that Amadeus is said that it's supposed
to be based on a real person and while
fictionalized is okay
this is irresponsible and then it's
showing a real person in a fictionalized
way without explaining that this is a
completely a dramatic eyes story that is
unde is not indicative of the actual
person on top of that it goes out of its
way to try to heighten drama in
situations that are unnecessary it has
wasted casting and in multiple
situations it just stops the piece
completely to just play music for an
extended period of time without having
that be Ana trinsic the plot expediting
the story whereas almost famous every
single piece of music every single
moment every single soundtrack that you
listen to every song on that gives you a
moment in that movie that resonates that
has emotional connection that is only
achieved by the real realism and by
having a love for your work that Cameron
Crowe clearly does in this movie that is
somewhat autobiographical that he is
using to show as they love to music and
to musicians that are showing musicians
from all aspects instead of a limited
perspective from just the creative angle
Thank You Elena Bibbs go ahead and wrap
it up almost famous is about music
critics almost famous is about music
appreciation it is not about the
specific musicians in the narrative they
are side characters they are excuses in
order to get the fan experience and it's
not about the best movie about fans it's
about the best movie about musicians
whiplash yeah technically he's a
musician but really the music is
completely incidental again you can tell
the exact
narrative without the music and it's the
same movie Amadeus is about people who
love music who actually make the music
it stops to show you the music because
you need to have the dramatic comparison
of great music to adequate music without
actually showing the musicians play the
music which they don't really do in
almost famous you don't get a full
portrait of the artist and again they
said real or fictional the fact that
Matthias is fictionalized is inherent in
that it is a movie recreation of things
it is based on a true story it is not a
documentary therefore that is a
completely moot argument Amadeus shows
music from every single perspective and
actually appreciates the music and shows
the music and loves the music in a way
that neither of those phones do all
right time Wow how about it it was
flying in that round a lot of passion a
lot of passion Dan Moreau why don't you
give us some facts and then go ahead and
weigh in with your thoughts on the
rounds sure as far as factually again
not talking about movies that factual
eyes this that factually ones tiny thing
which is that whiplash just not the
directorial debut from Damien Chazelle
you've done one other movie called guy
in Medellin on a park bench before
whiplash yeah so just rejected yeah I
remember I saw the movie so I should so
I it's between Viviani and ace for me
and and I it's it's difficult it's
really hard because I was kind of all
ace but Viviana had a great closing
argument that really drove things home
with Amadeus but I still think again
like I felt like the biggest argument
against whiplash for Viviani was that it
didn't treat music and a good light
which you know I agree but I don't think
that should invalidate it as a choice I
think that's a personal opinion and then
the only argument I really heard against
whiplash from Elena was that it was
unrealistic which again I don't that
didn't really hit home with me is again
I think she's deemed it unrealistic that
I just don't think the negatives were
there enough against whiplash whereas
there were negative sporadic estaba days
there were negatives brought up against
almost famous I thought they were
stronger arguments against and I liked
the arguments for the fact that the
flash was focused on a musician and what
music does to him good or bad
I agree but as far as its effect on him
I gotta go with ace I am live life BAM
that's one for Ace
Elena you absolutely I think you picked
my favorite movie of these three so
unfortunately they took it down when
they say then when they said truthfully
that the film is framed from the critic
slash fan perspective and that's that's
a tough one because almost famous is a
gem of a movie so it also came down to
bibs and ace for me and I feel like just
both of you were coming at him without
and what a negative portrayal of abuse
it was and yeah abuse is ugly but it's
also it's also a real thing and art
doesn't have to be beautiful and pretty
all the time I was I mean the film was
evocative bibs you made some great
arguments though but at the end of the
day I gotta agree with Dan and go with
ace as well with whiplash so ace takes
this point
Bradford wow that's real thirsty for a
second so I had to the final tally of
the polls Thank You Chad I see y'all
let's keep Amadeus with 48 percent
whiplash with 35 percent an almost
famous with 15 percent we got a lot a
lot of love for Purple Rain a lot of
love for Rockstar which look what
Rockstar is amazing that's pop star he's
wearing his Kurt Cobain sweater and like
Wow beautiful
a lot of straight out of Compton you
went really genuinely legit hard for
walk hard and not walk behind what hard
I'm intrigued I say one quick thing I
know one movie of that year I still
maintain that my biggest argument was
that music was irrelevant but okay I'm
dition for the lead role and almost
famous obviously I didn't get all right
it's uh it's two ouais but there's
plenty of game left question number
three the Khan film festival wraps up
this Saturday what is the best movie to
ever win the Palme d'Or at Khan the best
movie ever won the Palme d'Or at Khan
Elena we're gonna start with you I am
going with the 1994 Quentin Tarantino
masterpiece Pulp Fiction which has had
more of a cultural impact for most fans
and filmmakers than the majority of the
movies who have been featured in can
whereas this one also was able to take
an eight million dollar budget turn it
into over a hundred million dollars when
it was initially doubted especially
because of Quentin Tarantino going for
the nonlinear editing structure which at
that time was somewhat revolutionary and
because the violence is perfectly
orchestrated all of the characters are
fully realized and the full moving
creates such an lasting impact this
movie has basically become a phenomenon
that I think is unparalleled to the
majority of the movies that not only one
but were even nominated alright Elena
going with pulp fiction around the bend
to bits the movie I picked is not about
Vietnam it is Vietnam it is Francis Ford
Coppola 1979 masterpiece Apocalypse Now
it's an adaptation of Joseph Conrad's
timeless work hearts of darkness and it
is about Vietnam a as a war as the
experience of a war not from unobserved
from an objective outside opinion but
from the thick of it from Deeping
delving walking directly into Hell
itself into a moral quagmire into the
beauty and
or of violence with some of the most
iconic performances in movie history
some of the most iconic cinematography
in movie history it is one of the
greatest films about war and the
destruction of the human spirit it is
considered one of the best movies of all
time and it is the best Palme d'Or
winner Thank You Bibbs ace I chose the
1976 winner which is taxi driver which
is Martin Scorsese's masterpiece it
stars Robert De Niro with a true
character exploration of a very bitter
man who comes back it's a true
exploration of masculinity of its time
but also it seems to be up this time as
well which to me is very relevant and
that is why it's my choice for the best
Palme d'Or winner awesome I already
loves this match I mean you got Coppola
vs. Scorsese versus Terran Teno fight it
out you guys knew deist question I think
I never had why I gotta say your opening
argument is one of the modes I have the
biggest problem with Apocalypse Now
which is basically it's three hours of
Francis Ford Coppola festival my movie
is not about Vietnam my movie is Vietnam
take a step down this is a very ill
paced shaky-cam movie where you're going
above and beyond to try to appear
artistic when in actuality it lacks a
lot of the heart and the full
exploration of Vietnam that
full-metal-jacket platoon Deerhunter
even good morning Vietnam encapsulated
without it's not asbestos hard
it's about hell that's a totally
different experience you're talking
describing a completely different movie
what you're doing is you're saying that
it's also this exploration of somebody
who is losing their mind in the jungle
which is true but because of the slow
pacing of it and because of the weird
editing and because of the camerawork in
it it's called art it's called
experimentation it's Haring all the
movies you liked in the 70s Apocalypse
Now is okay listen all of these movies
are by 30-something Italian Americans
and they're all about violence which by
the way I'm a little embarrassed by that
because the Kahn Film Festival is way
more broad than that but whatever let's
talk about this our films are both 1970s
motion pictures about the impact of
violence on the human soul Quinn
Tarantino's film is about the impact of
1970s movies about violence in the human
soul and their impact on Quentin
Tarantino and how much he liked the
surface [ __ ] sighs in style what's
the purpose what is it about in every
single moment that he has whereas taxi
driver also incorporates a whole bunch
of racial in situations good serving
Martin Scorsese actually in the backseat
with this whole silhouette way drawn-out
movie again pacing problems without
actually incorporating why he is
basically just I'm saying the n-word for
fun there's an actual purpose but that
is a dress I'm still waiting for it I
feel like it's difficult to say that
especially with Tarantino who's known
for using that also for me this is why
this movie is so relevant because it is
that bitter white man coming back and he
wants his way it's very no but for me
this is why it becomes relevant because
it is that bitter man defying a white
man and mows down because if you know
that he's a hero at the end turn t no
putting that in a movie saying how great
I am seven movies is character building
for an hour and a half we don't get into
the actual plot until 30 minutes into it
which is a sponsor has an amazing
performance where he scared with literal
sunglasses on her face for the majority
of her big scene which are taken off and
then replaced with inexplicably a
different parents she's still waiting to
hear what pulp fiction is about to say
fiction is a basically an ode to a
glorification of violence but then
incorporating a actual need for not a
need for violence but saying the purpose
of it and incorporating all of these
different racial stereotypes and saying
that it's a commentary on the actual
social justice what is your comment
here's my thing we just saw two weeks
ago for me showing a mirror to what
America is is something that can be
relevant it can be something relevant we
just saw two weeks ago a music video
that job called this is America from
childish gambino
which is very powerful very true to say
that 1976 taxi driver more powerful than
taxi okay so but for me this is what's
showing what the white perspective is of
a person who's black
get in the white no back what we need to
say that hard
alright time we're gonna call it there
Wow see that man blond apocalypse a lot
of passion a lot of points made Dan
Merle let's go to you for some facts
ding ding okay hmm that's I don't know I
don't know what to do with this one
I have no fact well I have no objective
abduct objective facts to address I'm
just gonna no facts to address no yeah
let's just gotcha
how you doing help pretty good pretty
good a lot of interesting points brought
up a lot of food for thought about the
content of these films and about these
films so we said there were three very
violent films made by Italian Americans
but I think there's three completely
different films
I mean taxi driver is this deep
character study Pulp Fiction is this
amazing a kind of unwieldy crime drama
that Tarantino very unwieldy deftly
weaves together and then um an epic
almost poem about war and so many great
points but at the end of the day it
comes back to a lot of the opening
argument that Bibbs laid out there on
why the transcendent fill I mean they're
all transcendent films but the movie
that was I think best laid out there was
Apocalypse Now
but yeah an impressive display to watch
but I give my point to Bibbs Dan Merle
yeah yeah we kind of we veered all over
the road so I'm trying to kind of gather
my thoughts in my head and put see who
put together the best case the
counter-arguments everything else I
think that I put together some very
interesting points and anna-lena
definitely had a lot of points against
but I feel like she was challenged
a lot on pulp fiction and didn't have a
lot of answers so I think the most
well-rounded argument and
counter-arguments came from from bid so
I'm also gonna give the point to Viviani
on this one
bibs taken the point right there Daniel
Radford talk to us alright he's saying
okay the voice of the people
we've got Apocalypse Now at 44%
pulp fiction at 38% and taxi driver at
17%
a lot of people were like do not make me
choose between these movies these
arguments a lot like super into the
arguments we've got some some people
throw in some love for Fahrenheit 9/11
which is another thing and then this
here's a tweet that I loved Corinne it's
both with two N's so see o ry and and
underscore w wrote tweets are slow right
now because everyone is googling what
Palme de or picture yes it is a plethora
of classic movies and I'm sure we all
had a really hard time picking and I
just want to say a choice before all
this these are all great movies yes
anything dank in the comments of
Cherbourg stands in the audience I'm
sure no it's very good a lot of people
are really just digging the
tenaciousness of this panel that is
fantastic yeah definitely getting after
it attacking the subject matter of each
film but three great movies and Jan
didn't get to rant they were like damn
looks like he wants to rat OH
Dan's always got a rant on deck if a
letter right yeah
so this sometimes I'm watching a fight I
just want to jump in and play damn that
makes one of the best except we've never
gone head-to-head it's coming man this
may never happen okay so we are headed
into the speed round with ace up 2 to 1
on bibs Elena
you brought it and saw some points and
wow I wish I had a better result on your
birthday you know what screw it you win
just kidding no I'm not allowed to do
the technicality I'm taking it no but
you brought it so thank you yeah for
coming in alright Peter
alright is how the speed round works
just a little reminder so it is two to
one ace right now first player to get 4
points awarded to them wins and the
first person to after asked the question
the first person to answer gets to
elaborate on their answer first it's 20
seconds 20 seconds then 10 second 10
second rebuttal alright y'all feeling it
no I'm actually really nervous okay oh
and bt-dubs Daniel Radford will be
giving our own opinion now because
there's no time for the Twitter poll
sorry
I'll keep looking for stuff oh you're
the best thank you okay first question
of the speed round this comes from Jack
Mannheim okay you're an ordinary
civilian on the street which movies
third act sequence would be the most
confusing to suddenly be caught up in
you're just walking down the street
normal and all of a sudden a movies
third act happens there what's the most
confusing to be said oh I like in real
life
yeah I can realize it just happens on
the street yeah okay
you talk Southland Tales I'm going
la-la-land alright Southland Tales
versus lala land bibs you spoke first so
20 seconds begin whenever you speak now
okay you're walking down the street and
then first Isle holy crap them in the
future there's a there's a [ __ ] van
like flying up in the sky and there are
two Seann William Scott's and they're
touching each other and they're shooting
stuff out of their bodies and what the
heck is happening and oh my god Dwayne
Johnson isn't like a blimp uh but the
hope above the street and the apocalypse
is having and oh my god what the hell
who is who is why why is the thing
la-la-land there's random people dancing
in the street there's a seven-minute
seven-minute like mash-up of literally
someone's life going on ahead of me
that's showing the future of a potential
life that is absolutely confusing I have
no context of who these people are why
they're dancing or what's going on if
that happened honestly I'm waiting for
the apocalypse to come it's probably
inevitable considering what's going on
in the news right now time
okay the ending of La Land doesn't take
place in the street it takes place in
the building and it takes place inside
people's heads so you're actually just
watching Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone
look at each other and I gotta tell you
that's not that confusing I think it's
confusing as hell honestly the
apocalypse coming to be is something
that I'm probably expecting to happen
whereas la-la-land I'm watching a life
of two people that I haven't seen before
I've never known I don't know why
they're singing I don't know who this
kid is I don't know what's happened to
her time Wow okay ace I'm sorry that you
have such a pessimistic view let's go to
Danielle Radford this is obviously an
incredibly entertaining argument but I
do have to say the bibs one me when he
mentioned that a lot of it does happen
in their head and you're essentially
just watching two attractive people
stare at each other in LA which happens
every day
anyway I gotta give this one okay that's
104 bibs
Alayna Jim any thoughts on this by the
way yeah I gotta say I agree but I think
sharknado would have been the best
answer yeah arrghh swine out of nowhere
the weather report said nothing it was
sunny clear day yeah that's a great
answer but yeah I also got to go bibs he
just laid out what would have been that
much more mind-blowing and I completely
agree with Danielle Radford it's LA
everywhere you look it's beautiful
people making goo-goo eyes at each other
right - mm great moment in sports okay
the sport oh my god it is okay it's 2-2
here is the second question of the speed
round this comes from Kristin litter
no Krista Wriston Ritter right
okay Kristin Runa though if you're
watching please send us questions what
is the best Tom Hanks performance that
he did not win an Oscar for castaway
five four going captain Phillips
captain Phillips okay we got castaway we
got captain Phillips 20 seconds begin
four bibs whenever he speaks it's
incredibly rare to see a film with as
big a transformation in a character and
an actor as you do in castaway he starts
off one type of person and then they
have to take a break for him to emaciate
himself in for him to get in the mind of
a character has been isolated for years
and then when you see that it's such a
huge moment and he has transformed
completely as a character and sinking
try to build his way back up again it's
like that scene at the end of captain
Phillips everyone loves right I'm
captain Phillips deals with him dealing
with a very difficult situation where
he's filled he's dealing with adversity
ahead of him and the personification of
these pirates that are coming on his
ship it doesn't know what to do
he's feared and and and when he realizes
that he comes into fruition of dealing
with his crew his people and at the end
of the film we see a performance that
literally has everything that has been
living up to my all in that castaway is
a more difficult situation it's more
adversity and unlike in Captain Phillips
when he has other actors to work with
it's all him for most of the movie he
carries an entire movie with just him
and a volleyball and it's never boring I
think all Kim gives him more time to
dive into that character with we're
dealing with other cast members and
dealing with other people and people who
are first-time actors has him developed
more as an actor and shows his true
ferocity as an actor time whew good
stuff right there Dan Merle what are you
thinking mmm
two good arguments but I gotta go with
Viviani on this all right that's a 104
bibs radford ah that's really hard
because well I do really like I love
aces argument that it you know having to
work with other people especially a
full-time actor that is a really good
argument but the I have to go with bibs
for the he does carry that all it's just
him it's him and a volleyball so I'm
going there you go Biff steaks at bibs
moves into the lead I would have given
it to captain Phil's just because as
that line I'm the captain now but
I know my judgment would have been very
flawed good thing they chose otherwise
thanks guys all right it is three two it
is three two this one gum comes from Dan
Harcourt Dan Harcourt if you had to have
one
movie soundtrack what would you want to
play loudly outside your house for an
entire week straight if you have to have
one
what movie soundtrack would you want to
have play loudly outside your house for
an entire week straight outside your
house as it's blaring outside of here
non-stop for a week straight okay you
know you know what I'm going with Creed
okay Creed
dibbs stop making sense stop making
sense the Talking Heads movie
okay so we have Creed we have stop
making sense let's see if these
arguments make sense
ace 20 seconds begin when you speak for
me if I want music playing outside my
house I want music that makes me feel
good I want music that lifts me up
I've bought music that makes me feel
inspired that makes me feel motivated
that makes me feel like I want to
succeed in life Creed brings that crate
has a soundtrack with true hip-hop it
combines traditional rocky themes with
hip-hop that's current too nowadays I
love hip-hop I know a lot of people do
too and that makes me feel inspired stop
making sense has a more varied
soundtrack which is gonna get a lot less
boring over the course of a week if
you're inspired 24/7 and everyone on
your block is you're also gonna start
jogging into each other the entire time
it's gonna be exhausting and boring
you're never gonna sleep with Talking
Heads there are moments of quiet there
are moments of subtly their moments of
romance you're actually going to have a
life as opposed to have your life
destroyed by soundtrack you previously
loved with those different variations I
don't know what kind of moods and themes
that are gonna put me in words with
Creed I do want to feel inspired I do
want to feel like I want to succeed in
life I don't want to have too many ups
and downs and I don't want to feel those
downs I want to feel inspired
talking-head does not have downs it has
contemplation at his moment it has
actual songs about living in suburbia
that's actually gonna be people
challenge themselves and actually think
to themselves well what is this
beautiful house where did I get here
time Wow
oh man two very different arguments two
very different sorry two very different
soundtracks you know what oh this is a
real pic of them for me just but I gotta
go I gotta go
ace on this one I like how he gave his
perspective and how he would enjoy that
and that spoke to me that much more so
I'm going a Danielle um I have to go
with ace as well as much as I was with
bibs up until you said it might make
them challenge like they're everything
on the block I don't know that I want
all of my neighbors going through an
existential crisis
cool everyone's suddenly taking up
painting or whatever it is that they
they dropped when they were a kid so I'm
going to go with this right on ace
takes this point Elena did you think of
an answer for that one
yeah I would have gotten with Josie and
the Pussycats because I love that
soundtrack you never get sick of it but
other people definitely would and so I
would have a week that no one would
bother me just being a great mood by
myself with my cat just three small
words rocking out everyone else first
one that came to mind for me was a Tron
Legacy a movie that didn't have any
music in it oh okay so we are tied up
three three it all comes down to this oh
this dome question number four the speed
round this is for all the marbles
who should get a spinoff first obi-wan
Orlando obi-wan Lando all right Obi one
says ace Lando says Bibbs ace twenty
seconds begin whenever you speak obi-wan
Kenobi is the greatest Star Wars
character of all time we see him not
only develop from what we see in the
prequels we see him what we get with
Alec Guinness but with even McGregor
everyone's favorite part of the prequels
was even McGregor he was fantastic in
that people are ready to see an obi-wan
Kenobi movie where he kicks ass where
it's his individual movie where we get
to see him explored in his
characterization
first off how great would it be to see a
Star Wars movie that isn't about a white
person we actually have different
experiences throughout the whole galaxy
Lando Calrissian is played by Donald
Glover now is absolutely fantastic I've
seen Solo he steals that movie he is
funny he is sexy he's charming and he
represents a side of this that we really
haven't seen before a character whose
backstory is almost completely unknown
whereas with obi-wan of Jedi time I love
Lando Calrissian but like you just said
we just got so low a Star Wars story
whereas we haven't had that follow-up
from the prequel characters and I feel
like even when Gregor is the perfect
bridge right now especially with the
Star Wars fandom to bridge the gap we
had to follow from the prequels it was
called the original trilogy Lando
Calrissian is a side character in a film
now and now he is better than he has
ever been before and we want to see more
of him people wanted to see more of him
before they saw solo the trailer and I'm
wow Dan Merle what are you thinking I
it was very very close but I think we
got a clinched it for me when he said
that you know we've had a follow up to
you would McGregor and that's the Star
War the original trilogy where as Lando
is a side character I'm gonna go with a
bit beyond this one 104 bibs Danielle um
yeah I have to agree with that one
because specifically when you mentioned
that it would just be more Jedi stuff
and we've kind of already been really
steeped in Jedi stuff and the idea of
getting to explore a character whose
backstory we haven't seen a lot of would
be really interesting so gotta go with
bibs big stakes
come-from-behind victory
don't you get up on the table and say I
am a golden God bad knee okay and this
is a glass table you know it'll hold
yeah Wow what about bibs Congrats you
came back from down - oh and you took
the whole damn thing you know what your
orders go ahead and plug something oh
man I love plugging things I'm - pod
cast aside the cancel too soon pod cast
would you listen to an iTunes we review
television series that lasted only one
season or less this week we're reviewing
the notorious cop musical cop rock
really really really amazing
what's that cancel two shows that's the
question we answer and oh yes okay we
also have critically acclaimed of the
schmoes no network where we review new
movies and also do a double feature of
one of the worst so one of the best
movies ever made every single week I
also write for the rap n IGN and you can
follow me on twitter at william Bibiana
thank you sir and congrats on a
well-fought victory - also well fought
so damn close ace this was your first
full movie fight and you brought the
pain brother go ahead and tell us where
we can find you
yeah check me out on the meaning of
podcast I mean enough podcast is a great
podcast that I started with my buddy is
name is Robert Butler we talk about
films and filmmakers so we go through
each director and we dissector
filmography we talk about tones and
themes that keep coming up I'm also
gonna do more from my YouTube channel
which I talked about anime so I'm gonna
talk about my hero academia and Tokyo
ghoul oh that's cool awesome that's very
cool ace thanks brother um Elena thank
you so much you gave some great answers
and I wish I could have awarded you a
point in the speed round for sharknado
because that was the best tell us how
where we can find you please you guys
can find me on twitter at alina jordan
and on instagram at that elena jordan
girl i'm also hosting a whole bunch of
different TV shows on afterbuzz TV so
you can see me recap and review and some
different TV shows and also in VHL
online also host on DC movie news on
popcorn talk network and tickets are on
sale now for both amazing cons in Las
Vegas
June 29th through July 1st and in Hawaii
amazing Comic Con Aloha August 24
through 26 I'll be up both so if you're
there come see I just like I've never
been to Hawaii I want to go to a con in
Hawaii best convention I have ever been
to in my entire life
amazing just like cheering a lot cheers
in lava flows with Chris Claremont it's
amazing it's cross 'im thank you all
Elena Dan Morelle great work as always
thoughts comments concerns random non
sequiturs oh no nothing really
all right the folks wanted to see
whatever your rant was gonna be I'm
getting a lot of people yeah you know
what yeah the answer will be on the DVD
extra it's good to walk okay Danielle
thoughts you know just the same as usual
follow me on instagram Danielle
underscore Radford at Instagram and
that's it and follow me on Twitter
because anytime I do any fun videos here
or any weekend content I'm gonna be
plugging them in those places as well so
if you want to make sure that you see
all the cool stuff we do over the
weekend make sure that you follow us and
we will let you know heck yeah
thank you as always and I want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick you can
hit me up on Twitter or Instagram at Hal
Rudnick also if you're in the LA area
this weekend coming up to the UCB
theater on Franklin Saturday night for
my long-running show the tournament of
nerds so many fun people in it and so
much a lot of screen junkies folks make
appearances and uh familiar faces yeah
it's a fun comedy pop culture debate
show UCB LA this Saturday night at
midnight crazy and I want to thank Billy
biz jte and everyone who is a part of
this and thanks again bye-bye
you